Congratulations. You've completed this course.
>> Thank you for taking the time and effort to do so.
>> And we hope you've appreciated taking this class as much as we have creating
it.
>> And we want to give a special thanks to everyone who made this possible, from
our guest experts to our team here at Udacity, with a special thanks to Calvin
and Kugory who helped us produce this course.
>> And now that we've come to a close in the course
>> We hope you can fully appreciate understanding psychology; that is human
thought and behavior. Both scientifically and clinically and about sometimes
how these processes can go wrong, but if they do there are treatment options to
help people.
>> That's right. And we also hope you appreciate the complexity of our brains as
well as knowing that we need to have a healthy brain to function successfully
in our world. In addition, we hope that you appreciate the environment and how
that shapes our behavior, and how it's really a combination of both nature and
nurture that makes you, you.
>> And because we're dedicated to making this the very best course we can make it.
We hope that you can give us feedback on this anonymous survey to tell us what
you liked, what you loved, and what you thought needed improvement. And even
though you're done, check back in from time to time, because we're going to add
new material.
>> And you can further your knowledge on Psychology.
>> 'Kay, cut. That's a wrap.
>> It is a wrap.
>> Yay.
>> Woo. [clapping]